you know what i also have mike
it's a new thing hypernova yay dayton's
been [ __ ] prolific lately
get a camera day i'm going to read the
title of the video as uh as this
tradition here
uh transphobic home life religious
right-wing neighbor believes
queen is a hoax part three
again we're in the sun chips bag you
would have got it your mom
your dad i would have got it i come over
here all the time
is that a black guy he's talking to a
black guy all right that's gonna be
great
hey rusty you see what i'm saying
your uncle larry chose he came over it's
been about
two or three weeks ago he come over one
day and we're sitting there we're doing
a bible study we gotta
let's go get some lunch and
at the time i didn't understand why he
wanted to go to burger king
but this one uh i don't understand why
anyone want to go to berg
and then i realized that he was black oh
so it was like well you know
it's one of the few places that has
gluten-free
buns and gluten
makes him sick no messes and no it
doesn't so anyway we
i told him my gamer's choice by the way
i want to just tell you people all you
[ __ ] gluten facts right
none of you are allergic to gluten
there's no such thing as a gluten
allergy
the gluten you're not special that like
whoa gluten really [ __ ]
what are your celiac disease
gluten messes me up look gluten [ __ ]
everybody it's just
we're just coming to find out that
gluten is not a great thing
you power through it for anyone you
power through it but it's like you know
what i mean
that's like saying man i don't know what
it is man it's something special about
me
that like carbs really do something to
me man they really make me tired and
sluggish
like no that's literally every person
that eats too much carbs is gonna be
useless
celiac disease so we go to burger king
and when we get there we get to the door
and they got a big sign
no service without mass you know without
entrance i don't want any more kid in
place so i was putting my masks on when
i seen
it so i told you uncle larry i said uh
larry you got to go back to trump and
get your mass
so it made him pump because he had to
walk all the way back to the truck
now listen to the words
this is important
so after we go in we get our lunch and
we come back out
he says well if those mass was
doing all what they say they're doing
and how good they are
how come the numbers are spiking and
going straight up
i said oh that's a good point they tell
us we
got to wear these masks but they're
catching all these officials that's
telling us that we're
not wearing them when they're impressed
what is that trip
it's driving me and i'm sorry i don't
even it's
driving me insane
i i'll be honest there's very few things
in the world that drive me nuts
a drip will always do that that and like
the beep from a um
smoke detector beep from a smoke
detector is bad
but there's something about that drip
where i
like i will i'm i'm not very fussy when
it comes to a lot of things
i will absolutely change
hotel rooms if there's a drip like
that's one of those things
it may seem small but i'll be like i'm
sorry can i get another road like i've
tried i can't do this
this drip is gonna like i'm gonna be a
murderous madman by the morning if you
don't change this room for me
work and make a lot of money
[Laughter]
uh every
day now i'm trying to see
so he tied up this phobic home life have
you heard any any trust any traffic talk
yet
not particularly but all right here we
go
now your mom has an interesting story
about her beautician
a beautician you tell me by the way this
sounds like a hell of a confrontation
that dayton caught onto yeah this is
crazy
because this is fiery her beautician
told her that four of his friends
went in up in miami county to get tested
at the burger king everything's in there
that's all you know that's how many fast
food place they have in dayton
there's burger kings it's all of them
that's it only bird cakes
they signed all the papers and turned
the papers in
they sit there for the first hour
nothing happened
sit there the second hour third hour
come they said you know what
this is crazy we don't sit there all day
so they got up and left and then we got
tested
you know what your mom said she said my
son is a disappointment
and my other one is even worse
god damn i was gonna do the second line
you [ __ ] she took it from me
she said to me she looked me right my
eyes she said roger
i don't know i'm just assuming his
name's right right roger [ __ ] roger
some days i just want to kill myself
because my sons have let me down
we had two not one but we had three
children in this family and only one of
them went on to do anything
and that was simply just have kids
sister lives across the streets a
beautician told her
what was it a week later two weeks later
yeah about a week later they sent him uh
and they never even took the test
now do you understand the big scheme
it's all about taking the money
but you noticed something about dayton
dayton danger recording danny gets all
uppity with his dad with his old dad and
with his mom but with this blood-based
black guy
notice how he's like um uh-huh yeah i
guess it's a simple matter of man you
raise your voice to me again oh
[ __ ] i will smack some skin flakes off
of you all
[ __ ] a heartbeat i'll smack you so
hard when you go back in that house
you're gonna be
the exact image your parents imagined
you'd be
i'll smack you so hard i'll turn you
back into a man
imagine a black guy hits him so hard
that his next video he's just like hey
guys how you doing uh my name
or my name's earl schultz he just starts
going this whole you're like wow
earl just is back to being earl again
and i'm an accountant now i actually
just got a job uh well you know it's
really i'm just at the gas station
working at the register but that's just
why i put myself through school at night
uh i'm actually in a trade school now
for woodworking so i'm learning how to
uh
carve my own cabinets out of rare
brazilian rosewood
just like what happened to him oh this
black guy smacked him really hard
they're just like this black guy's like
some kind of magical genie
you start sending them around the
country to fix your kids
they're taking our attachments i'm
paying for it that's what they do
and they tell me about you
uh is making millions and he was
supposed to be the number one guy over
um you know stuff like that anyway
anyway girl wake up anyway earl wake up
don't stay asleep and think oh well you
know
uh i mean one thing is don't stay asleep
and think that you can just walk in that
healthy store
because i was shocked when i went there
i've never seen it like that
yeah they very seldom i mean in the
years i've been going there
it might have happened once or twice and
i've been going there 10 years i've been
going there since uh
[ __ ] when they start letting black folks
in there dating
last year was that about two years ago
i walked in there in 10 years
and it's happened twice that they didn't
have
that tumor
and when they and this last time they
told me
they was basically saying oh well you're
gonna have to order it
because we can't keep it now turmeric
we're talking about two more kelps
so a lot of people are taking it now so
they can't keep it
that's right see they can't keep the the
the turmeric so like what's happening it
right is that it's obviously a cure it
has nothing to do with the fact that
covert is [ __ ] up supply chains
across the country
no and causing small business to run out
of all
top everyday items like you know what i
you know what i had uh trouble finding
when i went shopping last night
milk really pretty sure that milk does
not cure covet
no pretty sure that although i did ask
the guy at publix last night i'm like is
there something i should know about
because
now i want more milk like i was only
gonna get a half a gallon of milk now i
want three gallons of milk what's going
on with the milk
they just somebody blew through all the
milk i had to buy that green wise [ __ ]
ew i hate that overpriced [ __ ] yeah
but
it was on sale but it was still like
dude it was a whole wall of milk gone
except for obviously two percent of
skims
and i was and they were like oh yeah i
guess uh we only got two percent in skim
and i'm like
i'm not buying i i refuse to drink that
it's just milk water
like it's disgusting but yeah i got the
green wine stuff but yeah i'm pretty
sure um
sir that it's just when i saw that last
night i didn't go
man i guess milk is curing all the covet
and everybody's
rushing to buy the government must be
hoarding all of the milk
no it's because supply chains it's
because kovit it's because
layoffs it's because there's less
truckers and farmers there's less
everything right now
by that logic dad this rock keeps away
tigers
[Laughter]
do you see any tiger i like to buy that
rock lisa
no dad i was just watching she takes the
money and she just takes the money
the other one that's the one that yeah
that's the one that stops your
white blood cells yeah okay
but what i noticed was
one night i was sitting there and i
drunk a glass of wine after drinking
that
tea see i put it in my teeth
yeah and boy i was like
and i was like so that's the reason i
warned you yeah you don't want to drink
and do that okay yeah
oh you gonna do that
okay he sounds dayton sounds drunk but
before we keep playing that
so this guy comes over and he's trying
to help him out with getting turmeric in
the store and
dayton being the good human being he is
secretly records a black guy
he calls him transphobic and religious
right-wing neighbor believes covert 19
is a hoax this is what he does to this
this guy that just came over to go
hey they could probably special order
turmeric for you he secretly recorded
him
but he does he's just [ __ ] he he has
absolutely no consideration for anyone
else i'm so glad that wasn't the
turmeric itself because that would have
been even worse
because it was we got several different
things so i got them all mixed up in my
mind as far as which one did what
i was like that sucks but i like can't
even have a glass of wine at all without
that happening
but that writes oh that's the that's the
other stuff that's good for me but it's
not the turmeric
i don't have to do that every single day
or is he nervous around black people
i think he wants to [ __ ] this black no
no no he [ __ ] women remember he doesn't
[ __ ] men
seriously he's been he's been very clear
about that
just like that like it made it
that much someone's at the bar shitty
[Music]
but also every second 30 seconds it
drips
it's a dripping grandfather clock it's a
known
it's a family heirloom it's a
grandfather clock with a with a shitty
urethra
i had like a sip not even i didn't i
drink a lot like a sip of wine
and i was like what's going on
it's like it was just like everything
was spinning it was like everywhere
i was sitting there watching programs
the old man's was watching his programs
and i had drunk
i had taken the amino acids earlier
with tea and then i decided to drink a
glass of wine
yeah i'm really trying to get to the
phobic part of this uh we're almost done
maybe it's the last minute and it was
close to bedtime
and i drunk that glass of wine and when
i woke up the next morning i was like
whoa
yeah whoa
so yeah and jerry can take one glass of
wine don't hardly affect me
okay so for one glass of wine and i'm
waking up like this
okay i supposed to do this every single
day i'm like i was freaking out a little
bit
it sounds like he's having a fun
conversation with him can somebody
explain to me why this is title
phobic home life because dayton
hypernova is a disingenuous mentally ill
deceptive little kid
i just thought that would explain okay
i'm sorry i apologize i never
wasn't aware that that's what he that's
what he was